how can I keep my daughter nine years
old away from these dangers from the
Internet only two things one you
actually don't let her spend time on it
which as you know is very hard because
everybody in her world will be on it two
and this is the most important the only
way I have a 13 year old daughter and I
think about this a lot this is my number
one thing that I'm most passionate about
period in the end of world number one
way to protect the child is to build
their self-esteem when a child is not
insecure they don't succumb to Danger
make sure she's confident about who she
is her brains isn't overly reliant on
how she looks build her actual
self-esteem because you're not going to
be able to watch her every minute no I
can but but if you make it I know you do
which is why I'm telling you this I can
sense that you realize it if you make
her confident and who she is but she's
amazing the way she is she will not
succumb to other people and that is how
she will navigate thank you very much